et pour y voir clair nous sommes ce
matin avec philippe froguel chercheur
généticien professeur à l'impérial
college de londres également à
l'université de lille il est l invité de
la matinale olivier de 40 flec
[Musique]
philippe froguel bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ce matin dans la matinale
d'air france alors on vient de le voir
le brésil comme d'autres pays avaient
parié sur l'immunité collective au début
de la pandémie
on voit que ça fonctionne pas
aujourd'hui pourquoi à la question de
manaus et compliqué parce qu'il ya
plusieurs facteurs qui doivent
intervenir et en particulier vous l'avez
remarqué la population de manaus et une
population indigène un d'indiens
d'amazonie et il est possible que
génétiquement
il réagit différemment à ce virus que
que les européens
et ça c'est une piste qu'il faudrait
absolument l'été dit il ya eu un sérum
de publications comme montré que la
génétique joue un rôle dans la réponse
des populations mais attend il ya
probablement aussi une variante
brésilienne tu peux intervenir mais pour
autant les etats-unis la grande-bretagne
aussi avaient parié sur l'immunité
collective et pourtant ils ont fait
marche arrière
l'immunité collective coûte trop cher en
vies humaines a aujourd'hui et aussi au
niveau des systèmes de santé pour
l'atteindre et donc les pays riches ne
peuvent pas se permettre leur opinion
publique ne peut pas se permettre
d'avoir des millions de morts pendant
deux ans jusqu'à ce que tout le monde et
était en contact avec la maladie et
justement l'immunité par la vaccination
est ce que ça fonctionnerait mieux
est ce que le vaccin immunise plus
longtemps qu'une infection par le virus
par exemple
aujourd'hui on a une expérimentation
dans un pays qui s'appelle israël est à
peu près 30% la population qui a été
vaccinée à 2 80% aujourd'hui des
personnes de plus de 60 ans et c'est
andy situation explosive où il y avait
énormément de cas et les premiers quinze
jours on avait l'impression que ça ne
marchait pas mais en réalité ça comment
marcher et on voit enfin pour des
vaccinations qu'ont débuté la dernière
semaine de décembre
il ya une diminution des cas aujourd'hui
avec des gens qui ont été en général
vacciner qu'une seule fois
parce qu'il ya la question aussi de ces
nouveaux variants qui arrive un peu
partout qu'est ce qu'on en sait ce que
le vaccin sera véritablement efficaces
contre ces nouveaux variants je crois
que c'est l'armée israélienne qui ont
douté justement il ya bien entendu une
inquiétude notamment pour le variés un
sud africain
le laboratoire modern art publié hier
des données rassurantes mais fois que ce
soit vérifiée par d'autres que par ce
laboratoire
seul l'avenir nous en train de dire
exactement si ces nouveaux variants qui
sont arrivés mais a d'autres qui vont
arriver et probablement d'autres qui
sont encore plus inquiétant s'il va
falloir changer ces vaccins et la flore
même revacciner ceux qui ont été
vaccinés au début on ne sait pas si on a
les situations comme la variole ou des
situations comme la grille où il faut
vacciner tous les ans alors on l'a vu à
l'immunité collectif ça fonctionne pas
la stratégie vaccinale il faut attendre
le traitement on en est ou parce qu'on a
vu que l'allemagne a investi dans un
nouveau traitement pourquoi finalement
il n'y a pas plus de pistes dans ce sens
là l'art en france l'institut pasteur de
lille dont je fais partie avait
découvert un médicament qui était
efficace dans des cultures cellulaires
et des des poumons artificielle et on
est en train de d'essayer de commencer
les études chez l'homme et à vrai dire
c'est pas très facile parce que le mini
ambiant français a tendance à bloquer de
ce genre d'études parce qu'on nous
demande de faire d'abord des études chez
chez des macaques elle puis ensuite de
prendre notre temps
il ya comme un conflit entre l'urgence
de faire des choses et puis la façon de
travailler en france qui est très
bureaucratique parce que ça c'est vrai
que les citoyens français ils ne
comprennent pas toujours pourquoi on
n'essaye pas d'aller plus loin dans la
recherche sur les traitements pourquoi
on n'a pas finalement ce cette volonté
là aujourd'hui
l'histoire de la france a été
traumatisée par la l'énorme polémique
sur les proxys chloroquine et quand on
parle maintenant d'un nouveau traitement
on en a parlé en particulier au mois
d'août au nouveau premier ministre
jenlain castex est quasiment chars les
trottoirs quand on lui en a parlé
gouvernement était pas très intéressé là
dessus le seul qui nous a soutenus c'est
le président ma trempe qui a parlé de ce
qui se passait à la cité pasteur de
lille à bernard arnault et lvmh a donné
5 millions d'euros à l'institut pasteur
de guerre pour faire ses études
cliniques qui n'ont pas encore commencé
et c'est pas de notre faute c'est parce
qu'il ya une très grosse difficultés à
avoir des autorisations et à vrai dire
pas parce que j'en suis et j'en sais
c'est pas moi qui fait ses études
j'ai du mal moi aussi à comprendre tous
ces freins alors il nous reste quelques
secondes peut-être cette dernière
question la 1re confinement est sur la
table est sûre à l'étude
aujourd'hui en france c'est vraiment la
seule façon de faire reculer le virus
à vrai dire il ya vous avez peut-être
remarqué que monsieur delfraissy
président du conseil scientifique a dit
tout et son contraire en 24 heures et
j'ai entendu ce matin l'information que
le président macron étaient pas contents
d'eux des gens qui disaient rock ont
confiné tout de suite et d'une certaine
façon il a raison les gens comme moi lui
disent prêtes à bord qu'on sache où on
en est parce que les hôpitaux ne déplore
pas les réanimations encore moins le
nombre de cas augmente doucement et la
seule chose qui pourrait nous obliger à
coire confiné tout de suite c'est
l'explosion des variants anglais sud
africain ou d'autres
et là avec le retard qu'on a eu en
france pour analyser ces variants ils
sont tous à faire des analyses un peu
partout ce qu'on appelle la fameuse
étude flash qui a été fait début janvier
on sait même pas exactement quels sont
les résultats réels et une autre qui
commence cette semaine
l'exécutif est un peu aveugle je
comprends l'irritation du président de
la république avant de décider des
choses qui sont quittes une économie et
la cohésion sociale à savoir exactement
où on en est et collectivement la
communauté médicale n'a pas été capable
aujourd'hui donné les informations
claires grandement de la france merci
beaucoup philippe froguel d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin dans la matinale
verte et franc je le rappelle vous êtes
chercheur généticien un professeur à
l'impérial college de londres est
également à l'université lille 2